not und verzweiflung in beirut während
helfer weiter nach überlebenden suchen
entlädt sich auf den straßen wut gegen
die libanesische regierung schulstart
mit krone virus nach positiven tests
müssen zwei schulen in mecklenburg
vorpommern schon wieder schließen
hitze trockenheit und eine große gefahr
in weiten teilen deutschlands drohen
waldbrände wie hier im letzten sommer
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist für den sport dabei
einen guten eindruck von mir
es ist der dritte tag nach der so
zerstörerischen explosion in beirut nach
dem schock und der verzweiflung wächst
die wut der libanesen vor allem die der
jüngeren wut über untätigkeit korruption
und versagen der politischen klasse in
libanon
große teile der hauptstadt sind zerstört
die trümmerberge gewaltig etwa 100
menschen werden noch vermisst ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit
die zahl der toten steigt weiter auf
jetzt über 150 hunderttausende menschen
haben kein zuhause mehr und direkt am
zerstörten hafen von beirut am ort der
explosion steht unser korrespondent
oligarch uli schildern sie uns doch erst
einmal ihren persönlichen eindruck aus
beirut
man kann es eigentlich nicht fassen
diese stadt hat es sich wieder aufgebaut
wurde wieder aufgebaut nach diesem
furchtbaren bürgerkrieg in einer art und
weise die wahrscheinlich ziemlich
einmalig weltweit war mit einer tollen
architektur es war eine leichtigkeit als
vereine farben freude wie man sie
wahrscheinlich sonst in der welt nicht
mehr findet heute haben die leute
beobachten die von außerhalb offenbar
kommt die es nicht fassen können wenn
sie durch diese straßen gehen diese
verwüstungen sehen diese skelette
fenster rausgerissen fassaden es ist
letztendlich ein einziger albträumen
kann es nicht glauben es zielt ein
regelrecht runter die reportage wobei
roth heute vom kollegen league bald
überall im blut helfen sich die bürger
gegenseitig und mit den folgen der
katastrophe fertig zu werden
die vorläufige bilanz ist erschütternd
300.000 menschen sind ohne wohnung mehr
als 50.000 kinder darunter
es fehlt an allem fünf der größten
krankenhäuser der stadt sind schwer
beschädigt oder vollständig zerstört
große teile perus sind nicht mehr
bewohnbar der hafen zerstört das
gesundheitssystem in die knie gegangen
die lage ist düster
die opfer haben ein recht auf eine
gründliche unabhängige und transparente
untersuchung dieser explosion
doch der druck der eigenen bevölkerung
und der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft lässt die
wichtigsten akteure im politischen
machtgefüge des libanon kalt der chef
der mit ihren verbündeten hisbollah wies
im fernsehen jede verwicklung in die
katastrophe zurück so nasrallah habe im
hafen weder waffen noch bomben raketen
oder ammoniumnitrat eine internationale
untersuchung lehnt er aber strikt
libanesische sicherheitskräfte haben die
verwüsteten hafenanlagen inzwischen
abgesperrt 16 hafenmitarbeiter wurden
vorläufig festgenommen
wütende demonstranten machten gestern
ihrem ärger unweit des parlaments luft
polizisten wurden mit steinen beworfen
die menge wurde mit tränengas
auseinandergetrieben
den ganzen tag über suchten heute
rettungsmannschaften aus zahlreichen
ländern in den trümmern nach
überlebenden
darunter auch teams des technischen
hilfswerks für deutschland man sagt
immer man hat so ein zeitfenster aber
die realität hat uns gezeigt dass es
auch nach diesem zeitfenster immer noch
die möglichkeit gibt lebende
verschüttete personen zu finden und
diese hoffnungen die muss man einfach
aufrechterhalten weil sonst kann man
diesen job einfach nicht machen
auch drei tage nach der explosion werden
noch zahlreiche menschen vermisst
wir haben die wut auf die regierung
gesehen braut sich da was zusammen
ich glaube da braut sich gewaltig war es
zusammen könnte schon morgen stattfinden
hier in der stadt ist eine große
demonstration angekündigt gegen die
regierung
man muss auch verstehen dieses land ist
eine enormen wirtschaftskrise die
bankguthaben der leute wurden von der
regierung letztendlich veruntreut sie
sind abgezogen worden
viele haben alles verloren die preise
sind explodiert jetzt ist nichts mehr da
und jetzt diese explosion noch wohl die
halbe stadt in schutt und asche liegt
das glaube ich machen die leute nicht
mehr mit es wird eine weitere
demonstrationswelle in diesem land geben
die leute werden aufstehen zu werden
es ist ein weiter demonstrieren werden
sie fragen was diese regierung außer
gemacht hat außer sich selbst die
taschen zu füllen und dann muss sehen
was da in den nächsten tag auf uns
zukommt aber es wird mit sicherheit
nicht unbedingt friedlich sein
vielen dank für ihre eindrücke omega war
das aus beirut
wenn sie den menschen in not helfen
wollen können sie das gerne tun und zwar
durch spenden
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe libanon bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
finden sie auch unter spenden punkt
zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
und heute abend um 22.30 gibt es ein zdf
spezial mit einer reportage aus beirut
weitere informationen und hintergründe
zu dem unglück finden sie in unserer zdf
heute app zum thema corona das robert
koch institut meldet den zweiten tag in
folge mehr als 1000 corona neue
infektion innerhalb von 24 stunden
demnach haben die gesundheitsämter 1147
neue fälle registriert
der 7 tagesschnitt der auf zahlen der
johns-hopkins-universität beruht ist
ganz leicht rückläufig danach haben sich
790 menschen neu angesteckt gestern
waren es 800 besondere wachsamkeit
scheint angebracht gerade in einer zeit
in der nach und nach millionen schüler
wieder in die klassenräume
in mecklenburg vorpommern mussten zwei
schulen die gerade erst aufgemacht
hatten erst mal wieder schließen es gab
corona fälle christoph westerwelle gibt
uns einen überblick
neues schuljahr alles wird besser
vier tage lang durften sie das hoffen
hier an der ostsee grundschule dann die
nachricht einer von euch ist infiziert
seine klasse muss in quarantäne
die schule macht erstmal dicht die
nächsten zwei verlorenen wochen über die
sich alle ärgern
ich habe bock schule zu schule da kann
man was lehren wenigstens und zu hause
da kann man noch spielen das gymnasium
in ludwigslust dagegen fast im glück
zwar hat eine lehrerin cupid 19
aber seid ferienende noch nicht
unterrichtet trotzdem wird der
schulbetrieb gestoppt im
schnelldurchlauf wir haben wenn man mal
realistisch ist von der positiv testung
der lehrerin dem vorliegen das
testergebnis hatten wir nach 60 minuten
die schüler nach hause geschickt die
lehrer informiert die listen der lehrer
vorliegen und hatten den test termin für
die lehrer heute mittag schon
organisiert aber nur dem virus
hinterherrennen reicht offenbar nicht um
den schulbetrieb zu sichern
in einer gemeinsamen stellungnahme
drängen namhafte virologen auf weit mehr
sprechen sich zitat für das konsequente
tragen von alltags masken in allen
schuljahrgänge auch während des
unterrichts ausklingt schwer
durchzuhalten könnte aber doch nötig
werden wie die korona karte zeigt grau
das bedeutet keine neuen fälle in einem
landkreis eine woche lang zuletzt gab es
viel grau inzwischen aber immer mehr
blau das heißt momentan ist corona fast
überall ein bisschen und mit den
reiserückkehrern kommt gerade noch mehr
virus ins land also gilt so viel testen
wie möglich wie hier am flughafen
münchen ab morgen ist das pflicht für
alle die in risikogebieten waren aber
viele lassen sich ohnehin freiwillig
testen vielleicht weil sich der neue
ernst der lage rumgesprochen hat
dramatisch ist die krone lage derzeit in
mexiko mehr als 800 tote in 24 stunden
mittlerweile sind in dem land insgesamt
mehr als 50.000 menschen in verbindung
mit 19 gestorben
nur die usa und brasilien zählen noch
mehr todesopfer
besonders betroffen von der virus krise
sind auch in mexiko vor allem die
ärmeren britta jäger berichtet erst hat
hawthorne sehr all der seinen vater
verloren später starben auch seine
mutter und die tante an cupid 19
dass ihnen das virus einen teil seiner
familie nimmt hätte er nie für möglich
gehalten
als mein vater starb haben wir erst
verstanden wie ernst dieses virus
wirklich ist wir realisierten diese
situation hier ist wirklich schlimm und
erst dann haben wir angefangen wirklich
aufzupassen
mehr als 50.000 tote doch die
dunkelziffer ist in mexiko hoch es wird
kaum getestet
in den krankenhäusern werden sie der
lage nicht herr das gesundheitssystem
ist unterfinanziert es fehlt an
schutzkleidung mehr als 70.000 mediziner
haben sich bereits selbst angesteckt
sowie dr josé garcia in den
krankenhäusern haben wir keinerlei
protokoll
es gibt keine ansagen aus den chefetagen
oder der regierung darüber nach welchen
regeln wir vorgehen soll
die lockerungen der restriktionen zu
früh empfehlungen zu masken und sozialer
distanz widersprüchlich vor allem die
kritik an mexikos oberstem
krisenkoordinator wird schärfer die weiß
er aber zurück zu marschieren das die
todeszahlen auch darauf zurückzuführen
sind dass viele menschen chronisch krank
sind viele mexikaner halten das für eine
lüge und glauben dass eine chaotische
corona strategie der regierung viele
menschenleben gekostet hat der streit um
die gas pipeline nord stream zwei
eskaliert us-senatoren haben dem ostsee
hafen sassnitz auf rügen mit so wörtlich
wirtschaftlich vernichtenden sanktionen
gedroht
im hafen lagern unter anderem röhren für
die pipeline nord stream 2 soll
russisches gas nach deutschland
befördern
die pipeline verläuft von russland
lubmin bei greifswald die gesamtlänge
der pipeline rund 1200 kilometer 150
fehlen noch
die usa werfen deutschland vor sich von
russischem gas abhängig zu machen mathis
feldhoff
es sind tausende von röhren die letzten
150 kilometer der nordstream zwei
pipeline zwischen russland und
deutschland
sie lagern auf dem gelände des hafen von
sassnitz auf der ostseeinsel rügen in
einem brief drohen jetzt drei
republikanische senatoren trust am
kotten und ron johnson den
geschäftsführern und besitzern des
mukran port sassnitz betraten sanktionen
wenn sie fortfahren waren
dienstleistungen unterstützung für nord
stream zwei bereitzustellen zerstören
sie die zukünftige finanzielle
lebensfähigkeit ihres unternehmens heißt
es in dem brief persönlich von
sanktionen bedroht auch
ministerpräsidentin schwesig dem land
gehören zehn prozent des hafens diese
drohungen sind völlig inakzeptabel und
ich weise solche drohungen zurück
deutschland und ganz europa hat ein
eigenständiges recht zu bestimmen wie
hier zukünftig die energieversorgung
stattfindet cruz und kollegen sprechen
aus was präsident trump seit monaten
anheizt und sie bekommen gegenwind aus
der gesamten deutschen politik einen der
wichtigsten freunde und verbündeten mit
sanktionen zu drohen und dann auch noch
diese sprache zu verwenden
das kann nicht funktionieren es geht
hier nicht mehr um nur 10 2 es geht um
die verteidigung der souveränität der
bundesrepublik deutschland
wer entscheidet hier die amerikaner oder
wir derzeit ruht die verlegung der
röhren ein schweizer spezialschiffe im
letzten jahr vor den us-sanktionen
geflüchtet jetzt soll ein russisches
schiff weiter machen es liegt schon am
kai im hafen von sassnitz für die
deutsche wirtschaft spielen exporte eine
besonders wichtige rolle und in zeiten
von corona wird natürlich noch mal
genauer hingeschaut wie viele waren ins
ausland verkauft werden
im juni das sagen aktuelle zahlen vom
statistischen bundesamt sei es schon
deutlich besser aus als im mai doch das
bild ist nicht einheitlich andreas linke
berichtet
getriebe für nutzfahrzeuge fertigen sie
hier im werk 2 bei zf in friedrichshafen
voll ausgelastet vor allem die nachfrage
aus china treibt das geschäft ruhe
dagegen in berg 1 kabelstränge für pkw
sind nicht gefragt hier fallen schichten
aus das wird natürlich teilweise dazu
dass die mitarbeiter fragen wo ist
eigentlich die krise das sind aber
natürlich nur die mitarbeiter die in den
bereichen arbeiten können die das glück
haben dort zu arbeiten wo wir die gute
auslastung für den chinesischen markt
haben im juni ist der deutsche export um
13,4 prozent zurückgegangen im vergleich
zum vorjahr aber 14,9 prozent beträgt
die steigerung verglichen mit dem corona
mai und das je nach weltregion
unterschiedlich die exportzahlen in
china sind inzwischen sehr positiv dort
ist die krise gut überwunden in usa wo
die pandemie noch nicht überwunden ist
legen wir noch weit unter dem
vorjahresniveau hartmetall werkzeuge zum
fräsen stellt die firma horn in tübingen
her kunden sind zum beispiel automobil
oder maschinenbau branche in der krise
doch auch hier überrascht eine steigende
auslandsnachfrage
wir haben merkte dabei wie china wie
russland wie indonesien die mehr wie
doppelte bedarf in der zwischenzeit
entwickelt haben im letzten monat zu den
vorjahreswerten einzelne lichtblicke
also doch insgesamt wird es noch dauern
bis sich der export wieder erholt hat im
süden indiens ist ein passagierflugzeug
verunglückt offenbar ist die maschine
der gesellschaft air india express bei
der landung am flughafen von ko sieg
oder über die rollbahn hinaus gerutscht
und in zwei teile zerbrochen
zum zeitpunkt der bruchlandung regnete
es stark mindestens fünf menschen sollen
ums leben gekommen sein darunter auch
die piloten mindestens 40 verletzte
wurden in krankenhäuser gebracht das
flugzeug mit mehr als 170 menschen an
bord war in dubai gestartet
sie haben es gemerkt der hochsommer ist
damit sonne hitze und trockenheit und
damit steigt auch die waldbrandgefahr
schon jetzt geht in großen teilen
deutschlands die gefahrenstufe 3 4
und 5 nur der süden ist noch weitgehend
verschont aber das ändert sich in den
kommenden tagen wird sich bei
anhaltender hitze die brandgefahr weiter
verschärfen elisabeth schmidt berichtet
aus einem wald in niedersachsen
knochentrocken förster helmut beuke
führt uns in einen lichten kiefernwald
in der lüneburger heide monokultur wenig
unterholz wenn ein brand entsteht dann
meist hier unten im völlig ausgedörrten
gras ein funke genügt und es steht in
flammen
wir haben jetzt seit einiger zeit
konstanten ostwind mäßige bis teilweise
stärkere winde und durch die höheren
temperaturen geringe luftfeuchtigkeit
und stetigen wind werden unsere wälder
regelrecht gewöhnt das heißt also sie
wären trocken geblasen und die gefahr
steigt dadurch auch noch mal deutlich an
sonst in nordrhein westfalen in der
nacht zu donnerstag brennt hier eine
waldfläche in der größe von zwei
fußballfeldern
die feuerwehr konnte schlimmeres
verhindern in niedersachsens wäldern
werfen gut 20 kamera türme ein waches
auge auf die bäume die technologie
stammt aus der weltraumforschung jede
sekunde ein schwarz weiß foto welches
die waldbrand zentrale in lüneburg
auswertet wenn das jetzt eine ziemlich
weiße säule ist dann könnte man davon
ausgehen dass des rauches dann
telefonieren wir mit der leitstelle
sie schicken dann auf unserer empfehlung
hin schicken sie da die feuerwehr denn
hin und die schaut dann ob da was vor
ort brennt luftaufnahmen lüneburger
heide
erst gestern wurde hier alarm ausgelöst
die waldbrand zentrale und förster beuke
der das überwachungssystem mit aufgebaut
hat sind in höchster alarmbereitschaft
und nun zum sport norbert da wollte der
ball jetzt auch wieder in der champions
league vier achtelfinal rückspiele
stehen heute und morgen an
münchen spielt gegen chelsea das
hinspiel in london hatte der fcb klar
mit 13 0 gewonnen da dürfte morgen abend
in münchen eigentlich nichts mehr
anbrennen
die favoritenrolle sind haben sie flix
bayern ja gewohnt der
drei-tore-vorsprung beruhigend dennoch
ist der trainer gewarnt
wir haben den notwendigen respekt und
wir wollen jedes spiel gewinnen jedes
spiel auch super form wie wir das können
die bayern ohne kingsley koman der
muskuläre probleme hat alternativen sind
philippe coutinho und ivan perisic
josua krimi spielt erneut auf der
rechten abwehrseite meistertitel und
pokalsieg haben sie schon im visier
jetzt das champions league finale am 23
august und das würde bedeuten spätere
einstieg in die bundesliga ja und dann
hieße am 18 september das
eröffnungsspiel übrigens live bei uns im
zdf nicht bayern gegen schalke sondern
dortmund gegen gladbach so der heute
veröffentlichte bundesliga spielplan zu
europa league leverkusen steht als
einzige deutsche mannschaft im
viertelfinale
eintracht frankfurt ist raus alles
gegeben philipp kostet steht
stellvertretend für eine kämpferische
eintrag die lange an das wunder von
basel geglaubt hatte
um aber ein 0 2 aufzuholen müsse auch
die feinabstimmung passen was nach erst
einer trainingswoche schwierig ist und
wie es dann so kommt dem fußball am ende
trifft sogar noch der gegner 1 0 basel
weiter
genau wie leverkusen das dem 3 1 in
glasgow 147 tage später durch die abi
ein 1 0 im rückspiel folgen ließ und
sich nun aufs viertelfinale gegen das
grosse inter mailand freut
wir wissen dass es ein schwerer gegner
ist wir werden uns jetzt erstmal holen
und dann entsprechend vorbereiten und
schauen wir dass dieses spiel gewinnen
ja und dann stück für stück in den flow
kommen schon am montag ist es soweit
gerade mal um die ecke in düsseldorf
zweites formel 1 wochenende in
silverstone da dominierte wieder
mercedes das freie training und
sebastian vettel hatte wieder große
technische probleme mit seinem ferrari
diesmal war es ein ölleck das um stoppte
[Musik]
danke norbert und zum schluss noch mal
ein ganz anderer blick nach beirut aus
einer zerstörten wohnung dringt
klaviermusik nach draußen
[Musik]
musik im gedenken an die toten gespielt
von einer alten dame auf dem klavier
ein tröstlicher moment das wetter bleibt
heiß und trocken mehr dazu hat gleich
ist sind herr lee das war es von uns
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 10 uhr
zum heute-journal und wir freuen uns
wenn sie auch morgen wieder dabei sind
punkt 19 uhr einen entspannten abend
wünschen wir
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hitze stress
bedeutet derzeit für die bäume ein
großes problem sie werfen ihre blätter
ab oder sterben gleich mit das
baumsterben ist derzeit in den wäldern
ziemlich groß und daran ändert sich
wenig weitere hitze erreicht uns aus dem
südwesten europas regen es nicht dabei
und das setzt sich in den nächsten tagen
fort in der nacht gibt es eine tropische
nacht 20 grad so ist es definiert
ansonsten elf grad ganz im süden
deutschlands und morgen da gibt es viel
sonnenschein im westen und im süden und
auch nach osten verbreitet sonne nach
norden gibt es wolken aber die bringen
kaum schatten und die temperaturen
steigen bis auf 38 grad am niederrhein
37 grad im rhein-main-gebiet selbst im
osten wären jetzt 33 bis 36 grad
erwartet 28 grad an den alpen die
nächsten tage ändert sich an der hitze
wenig 25 bis 38 grad die höchsten
temperaturen und das gewitterrisiko
steigt etwas an aber viel abkühlung
bringen diese gewitter nicht ein schöner
abend